ever since the movie came out everyone's
been telling me you gotta see big hero
six you gotta see big hero six all the
critics loved it all the audience's
loved it it's been the number one movie
for a couple weeks it's just incredible
oh my god
big hero six naturally I got
pretty excited to see Disney do kind of
a superhero film as well I really
thought about it I don't think we've
actually seen one from them
I mean we've definitely seen heroes in
their movies but not as much comic-book
characters I paid my ticket went on in
and let me tell you I have never felt an
overwhelming sensation that a film was
100 percent okay it's honestly hard to
think of what else to even say about it
it's okay how's the fighting it's okay
how are the characters they're okay
how are the visuals they're okay to be
honest I'm really dumbfounded why so
many people are talking about this film
it's not bad it's not good it's just
okay it's about the most standard
superhero film I've seen in a while not
that it has nothing new it's just all
the new stuff is okay the film takes
place in the future with a boy named
Hiro Hiro is a boy genius who has an
older brother who's also a boy genius
but Hiro is also walking that thin line
of applying himself to do great things
or just using it to benefit himself so
his brother introduces him to a team of
other super geniuses and he decides he
wants to be a part of it but again to
the school that they're all in he has to
win this competition sure enough he
comes up with an invention that wins
everybody's eye but loses everything in
a fire including his brother a long time
later he comes across one of his
brother's inventions named baymax baymax
is kind of like a one robot hospital
he's designed to help people who are in
physical or even mental pain but sure
enough Hiro sees an opportunity to put
this machine to good use when he sees
there's a masked villain who's using his
invention for evil it's up to Hiro
baymax and his new-found team of
geniuses to not only find out what's
going on but to do it as what else a
super team I'm not gonna lie
literally I predicted who was gonna die
who was going to be the villain and
and how the movie was going to end I
won't usually mind as is more part of
the journey but this movie seemed really
bent on surprising us with its twists as
well as its comedy and both were
unbelievably predictable it was really
strange to see all these characters that
seem to be designed well but I felt like
I've seen them in a million other
projects
you got the stoner loser you got the
hyper geek you got the cool one who
chews the bubble gum and most of their
dialogue is just centered around the
fact that they're making catchphrases
that they're gonna repeat later and when
they do it is so Forrest and don't get
me wrong I know a lot of these superhero
stories have a lot of that traditional
manipulation saying catchphrases
defeating supervillains all that good
stuff
the superhero films have come a long way
recently movies like Batman The Dark
Knight and of course all the incredible
Marvel movies are coming out now which
ironically this is a part of our
light-years beyond what this movie is
trying to do the only thing that sticks
out about at all which I guess is kind
of traditional Disney is the
relationship between Hiro and baymax
it's cute simple that never seems to go
to forest
baymax seems to keep to his exact
programming yet we still feel something
for it's not like he breaks it and says
he wants to be human or something he
just stays the exact being that he's
supposed to be the best parts of the
movie are with him trying to help Hiro
deal with his loss when the movie focus
is on that element it's good but when it
tries to actually be a superhero film
it's kind of dull it's not like there's
no imagination put into it it's just
imagination I've seen in a million other
places it's not like I didn't see
characters I just kind of saw characters
that were ten years behind the curve but
like I said I can't think of anything
that was awful it was just kind of
predictable and kind of been done before
like a lot even sanfran Tokyo what an
idea combining these two cities together
but I mean look at it it's creative it's
not lazy or anything but doesn't it also
can't look like a million other
futuristic cities you've seen before
with a million other characters you've
kind of already seen before maybe if
they kept it more simple just focusing
on the boy in the robot I would have
enjoyed it a lot more
as is it's just all right nothing
terrible nothing spectacular just all
right
but maybe that's not what you'll think
maybe you'll go and see it a spectacular
like majority of people do fair enough
there's nothing really that bad in it
maybe I'm just not the right person who
can see the greatness in it if you're
really curious check it out for yourself